and the original dot-com era companies
were measured by how much money they
made the idea was that you sold a lot of
stuff and took in a lot of cash and that
was the way you could get a valuation
and then get acquired or do an IPO now
consumers don't have money anymore
people are poor so companies can't
really use revenue as a way of showing
what they're worth
plus they have no real business plans so
what they do instead is use likes as a
metric of their worth if a company can
have a lot of people saying I like it I
like it I like it then that more
ethereal abstract metric I've got a
million likes I've got 20 million likes
that becomes marketable so if I want to
sell a record and make money and go to a
record company or a CD company I can
show look my song on YouTube has 500,000
likes and the record company or the
sponsor will then promote my music not
even because they're gonna make money
with that music
but because then I'm supposed to sell my
likes my views my followers to their
sponsors so a guy like jay-z comes out
with an album through Samsung that he
gives away for free because what it
really did was installed spyware on
people's on people's Android phones that
could see what they were doing
so what jay-z was doing was rather than
selling his music he was selling his
likes a company like tumblr had no
revenue but they had lots of likes and
users who all clicked on each other's
stuff they had those phantom metrics and
with that they were able to sell
themselves for a billion dollars this
year Yahoo was taking tumblr the billion
dollars as a loss they're writing the
whole thing off because they didn't buy
a company they bought likes but this is
the new economy that we're in it's an
abstracted absurd essentially
meaningless economy all of these
company's Facebook Twitter Google
they're all advertising based they're
all market research based the idea is
that these companies will somehow
replace advertising and marketing and
market research and consumer data the
problem is all those industries combined
never account for more than three or
four percent of GDP they can't because
if advertising becomes the majority of
your marketplace who's left to advertise
if my talks are supposed to advertise my
books and my books are supposed to
advertise my TV appearance as my TV
appearances are supposed to advertise my
books where's the revenue that's the
problem in our society now is that every
company now is a data play or an
advertising play but how can the whole
Nasdaq stock exchange be one big
advertising play it can't you still need
enough razor blades and bananas and milk
companies to support all of that stuff
so it won't support the entire economy
so that's why we don't really use
revenue anymore in playing this out the
bottom layer of the Ponzi scheme which
is what we're in now where these
companies are still trying to get
shareholder value and IPOs on Wall
Street this bottom layer is made up
completely of likes it's made up not of
the revenue that the companies make but
the amount of likes the amount of
traffic the amount of data they can show
but if your company's endgame is what
they call a big data play that all the
data we collect is going to be so
valuable you've already lost
everybody's collecting data the one
thing that there is a glut of is data so
that's not what you want to be trying to
collect right now most business people
whether they're in investment banking or
whether they're the hungry little
startup people they are so oblivious to
the operating system beneath their
technologies that they end up really
driving their businesses off cliffs and
all I'm asking people to do especially
if their programmers especially if their
developers to look and say wait a minute
what am i optimized
my business for a my optimizing it for
the extraction of value from people in
places which is a losing proposition or
a my optimizing it to promote the
circulation of value between people and
places which is a winner's game the
whole point of a digitally distributed
economy is that it's networked its
distributed you don't redistribute the
spoils after the fact you don't say oh
I've made too much money I'm gonna give
back 90% of it now before I die into all
the schools and things I think need it
no that means you've had an extractive
silly sick business which let you get
hundreds of billions of dollars but
killed your marketplaces destroyed
public areas destroyed the planet No
there are three factors of production
Adam Smith everyone's known this land
labor and capital in the current VC
driven technology startup marketplace
the only one of those three that we
value is capital the VC makes all the
decisions and land and labor are left
out of the equation that's why we have
zillions of unemployed people and why
we're destroying the planet it's really
simple or if we include land and labor
the places where we do our business and
the people through whom we do our
business if we include them in the value
equation all of a sudden business is
positive rather than a negative on our
society